let's talk about the one piece Iceberg
no not the character the iceberg that
contains the greatest Mysteries and
theories in one piece I've already seen
a lot of videos breaking down icebergs
for different topics but as far as I
know there is none about one piece in
case you don't know the iceberg video
format is a system of levels starting
with popular and mainstream theories and
Mysteries of a certain topic the tip of
the iceberg that everyone knows and then
moving deeper towards the wildest and
darkest theories the internet has to
offer starting with tier number one
crocodile was born a woman rising above
the surface of the waters we have a
couple of tier one theories that you've
probably heard about before like the
theory that crocodile was assigned
female at birth Master crocodile the
first chichibukai that Luffy ever took
down remains to this day one of the
fandom's favorite villains in the entire
manga is cunning plans awesome sand
powers and an unforgettable laugh make
him stand high above more dangerous foes
even in if he was defeated by a pre-time
skip Luffy but the leader of Baroque
Works Mr zero if you will has a secret
even more secret than his own identity
moreover the knowledge of the secret is
known to one Emporio ivankov the ruler
of the kamabaka queendom and just what's
secret with the holder of the hormone
fruit be privy to well that crocodile
was born biologically female and then
thanks to ivankov's Powers physically
transitioned to become male in other
words crocodile is a trans man after all
oda's drawing of a young crocodile is
quite gender ambiguous Admirals vs
Monster Trio the Marines have three very
strong military forces the straw hats
have three very strong Pirates they will
fight or so the story went before Akino
earned a promotion and aokidi went off
to hang with blackbeards however that's
not going to stop fans from speculating
who the final matchups will be when it
comes time for the straw hats to take on
the strongest Marine Powers Luffy has it
out for a kaino obviously sanji's kicks
will have to stack up against Kizer
whose light speed kicks Zoro and
fujitora both have swords a match made
in heaven and what about greenball well
we just learned that aramaki is a highly
prejudiced individual and we happen to
have the powerful Fishman slash civil
rights Advocate jinbei on the crew as
well it's really not much of a monster
Trio anymore anyways but we're looking
forward to the Admirals vs Monster
quartet I guess one piece was the
friends we made along the way what is
the one piece well the greatest fear
among the fans is that the answer is
nothing there is no treasure no world
shaking Revelation like the old saying
goes life is a journey not a destination
finding the one piece was never about
material gain that's why all of the
treasure Seekers who only saw riches
were doomed to fail but the adventurous
Luffy and his crew who only wanted
Freedom will be the ones to attain it
the quote unquote real treasure was the
adventures they had and all the friends
they made along the way now that I think
about it the treasure being nothing
actually fits really well thematically
but thankfully orasensei has actually
gone on record saying that the one piece
is a physical tangible treasure so thank
godness the cop-out ending has been
avoided and we're getting something cool
and shiny in a few years time dragons
win logia fruit now normal absentee
fathers go out to buy milk real absentee
fathers go out to wage war against an
oppressive government though when Luffy
finally met his absentee father in lokai
own he was accompanied by a powerful
Gale that enabled the straw Hat's escape
from Captain smoker now this very
convenient storm tinged green for some
reason the anime seemed almost
supernaturally fortunate well so our
best guess is really dead while the
winds were Supernatural they weren't
supernaturally lucky if you get what I'm
saying they were just Supernatural in
the sense that they were the result of
dragons devil fruit power which is
likely a wind or storm fruit after all
this revolutionary who wants to overturn
the status quo could be said to bring
the Winds of Change and we all do know
that oda's up for some good word play
after all here and there so very
possible Zorro is from wano now this
popular theory is pretty much confirmed
Zoro was from an island named after the
shimotsky clan he definitely has some
lineage here but what we would still
love some answers on is who exactly he's
descended from he looks exactly like the
former daimy of the shimotsky ushimaru
however Oda has gone out of his way in
an SBS to deny that Zorro is ushimaro's
son despite very directly and obviously
hinting at it in the manga so is he a
nephew grandson just tell us who he is
Oda we're begging you literally carrot
for nakama now people seem to think that
the hope for this rabbit Ming joining
the crew is dead in the water she didn't
stow away when the crew left wano
shirking her responsibility as the new
ruler of zou instead karibu was in the
barrel Oda even played with our hearts
and mocked Us by having the sunny use a
special new technique the rabbits crew
in which the ship is propelled by a
Barrel House propeller that does look
like a rabbit but did you even consider
this yeah sure karibu is in the barrel
but you know what haribu can also fit a
lot of barrels inside him and what's in
those barrels carrots probably I will
not give up hope that carrot is still
stowed away inside of karibu swamp until
we get a direct refutation of this
Theory Theory you know never give up on
carrot because she'll never give up on
you Sanji is a prince alright give
yourself a round of applause one piece
fans you got this one correct before the
whole kick island arc tons of fans
predicted that Sanji would turn out to
be a prince all the way back in the
Baroque Saga he assumed the secret
identity of Mr Prince and so the theory
went that this was more than just a
nickname this secret identity held a big
secret after all in actuality Sanji was
going to be a prince and then quite a
bit later we received news that Sanji
was actually from the north blue and had
somehow ended up in the East blue
together with zeph during the
confrontation with Kuma Sanji revealed
that he'd be the ones who caused the
straw hats the most trouble down the
line there was also the running gag that
every single one of sanji's wanted
posters didn't actually show his face
for one reason or another however Andres
Rosa as soon as sanji's face was shown
his bouncy condition was change to only
a life pretty much proving that he was
connected to someone with a lot of power
in the one piece world and so finally we
learned that Sanji was in fact a prince
of the German Kingdom proving many
eagle-eyed fans 100 correct GARP is the
leader of Swords so in case you don't
know sword is this secret organization
within the Marines with the aim of
making the Marines a Force for good in
the worlds instead of a Force 4 propping
up the celestial dragons since two of
the most prominently known members of
Sword are Kobe and helmeppo who notably
trained directly under Monkey D GARP
well logic would follow that GARP
himself is the secret leader of this
organization seven moons we know that
Minx turned so long under the full moon
and that NL is chilling out on a moon
but a much more important question is
which moon now in the library of O'Hara
we can see a model of the one piece
planet and its orbiting satellites that
clearly shows 7 moons now if this is the
case does the world still have all of
these moons or were some of them
destroyed somehow or do we just
conveniently never see more than one in
the sky at once hopefully the scientific
Mastermind vegapine drops some more Moon
knowledge on us very soon annel's return
and speaking of moons NL is up to
something on that moon in his cover
story he reached a fairy worth and found
the ruins of an ancient civilization
that seemed to hold illustrations of the
ancient weapons he also used his devil
fruit to power up a bunch of long
dormant automatons all this and on top
he even met actual space pirates so
clearly annel is going to play into the
story again somehow as so so many cover
Story characters actually do so how
exactly are the straw hats going to
encounter this God of all gods once
again is he going to strike back down to
earth with a robot army or are the straw
hats much like the game stock did going
to the Moon 10th Titanic captain aokiji
the Blackbeard Pirates have 10 Titanic
captains but we have yet to find out who
number 10 is so far we only know of nine
Blackbeard crew members plus blackbit
himself but since Burgess is the first
Captain tiege doesn't factor into this
count he's the Admiral now there have
been a lot of wild guesses for who this
final Blackbeard crew member could
possibly be but the prevailing theory is
the former Marine Admiral aokiji seeing
kuzan go fully onto the Blackbeard crew
and the ban in his sense of justice is a
wild idea but we do know that aokiji is
currently allied with them in some
capacity the fact that we now know for
sure that he's actually part of
Blackbeard's crew hugely increase the
stakes when it's finally time for the
straw hats to actually fight Blackbeard
and Co monster points awakened zone now
it's heavily implied that the impul-down
jailers are awakened Zone fruit users if
that's so they'd be the first awakened
devil fruit users that we ever see in
the entire series unless there's
actually one we saw first and wouldn't
you know it they were actually a member
of the straw hat crew Chopper ingesting
three Rumble balls might have triggered
a forced Zone Awakening and so monster
Point May in fact have been the very
first devil fruit Awakening that we ever
saw in the series all of this and we
haven't even scratched the surface now
if you're an actual hardcore one-piece
fan you probably know all of these
theories and Easter eggs already but now
get ready to hold your breath because
we're diving down to see what the one
piece Iceberg holds in tier level 2.
Shanks Davey backfight among one pieces
so-called fans there are a lot of people
including me who think that the Davey
backfight and the long ring long long
island arc are boring and unimportant
real fans of course believe in foxy
Supremacy we also know that Oda Sensei
doesn't have any unimportant arcs in the
story just look at all of this guy Pia
deniers right now so how will the Davey
backfight play into the story again well
when it comes time for Shanks and Luffy
to finally meet again this theory has
that the two Crews will engage in a
friendly Davey backfight to celebrate
their reunion Rogers gomugomo fruits oh
yeah over the course of the series we've
learned of a startling number of
similarities between Roger and Luffy the
former and future pirate king the straw
hat belonged to Roger they share the
same secret dream so why not the same
devil fruits now this long-held Theory
believed that the former owner of the
gomogomanomi was none other than Goldie
Roger however kaido's recent statement
that Roger didn't have any devil fruit
Powers seems to pretty much disprove
this Theory so we can pretty much say
goodbye to our hopes for a stretchy
Roger all of usop's Lies come true the
Pirates attacking Sarah Village the
giant goldfish a huge mole a beautiful
swordsman with meat Usopp has told many
many lies throughout the series and one
Theory holds that by the end of the
story all of these lies will have come
true if that's the case I are they
really lies one major lie that we still
need to see come true is USO bleeding an
army 8 000 men strong we get close to it
in dressrosa but we still need to pump
up those numbers so let's cross our
fingers for the Giants of elbaf quina is
tashigi zoro's childhood friend kuina
was the Catalyst for his dream every day
that he strives to accomplish his dream
of becoming the world's greatest
swordsman he does it partly because of
his promise made to kuina however what
if she wasn't dead at all what if after
losing her memories she actually grew up
to become the Marine rival toshigi the
second hand to Smoker it wouldn't be
oda's first time using Amnesia as a plot
Point looking at you big mom and Sabo
after all toshigi looks just like Weena
and has a similar love of sorts is this
more of an Easter eggy coincidence or is
there more to this entire story here
Luffy will get Roger's disease now
before Roger's execution he was
diagnosed with an incurable disease so
in the ongoing list of things that Luffy
has inherited from Roger will he too
contract pirate king anidas will the
story end just like it began with the
death of a pirate king after all we've
gotten lots and lots of hints throughout
the story about Luffy's shortening his
lifespan your second shortens his
lifespan his adrenaline treatments from
ivankov shortened his lifespan a side
effect of gear 5 appeared to be
temporarily transforming into an old man
so will this spell the end for Luffy is
this exertion related to his incurable
disease the same one that Roger had good
thing that the Thousand Chinese doctor
has a goal being able to cure every
disease in the world because Luffy might
need it the egg on Roger's ship in many
flashbacks we can see a massive egg
incubating on the back of Roger's ship
the Oro Jackson now what could have
hedged from a huge egg like this was it
Marco a dragon was it related to the
ancient weapon Uranus could the one
piece be the world's largest
omelettes many theories have hatched
from this giant egg oh my God this one
the most likely Theory well maybe it was
just tamago taking a nap Luffy's bounty
is 5.6 billion berries in Japanese gomu
means rubber or Gum as in the
gomukomonomi however the words gomu can
also be read as the number 56 5-6
therefore Oda has long Associated the
number 56 with Luffy as a child he's
seen wearing a shirt with the number 56
on it Lucy's Colosseum number was zero
five five six there are 56 members of
the Bartow fan club and the grand Fleet
numbers over 5 600. since Roger's final
Bounty was revealed to be a little bit
over 5.5 billion berries this theory
predicts that Luffy's final bouncy will
barely surpass Rogers and also keep with
the theme of Luffy being associated with
the number 56 and so his final Bounty
will most likely be 5.6 billion berries
the immortality surgery Andres that we
learned that loss ope opinomi has a
special ability in exchange for the
user's life they can perform these
so-called immortality surgery making
their targets Immortal now we don't have
much additional information about the
exact mechanics of this insane ability
but it doesn't seem like the thing that
Oda king of foreshadowing would casually
drop and then never bring up again
forget about chekhov's gun this is
chekhov's nuke as for who law may end up
sacrificing his life for it's a bit of a
mystery though Flamingo of course wanted
lot to use it on him but with the former
shichibukai now locked up it's a good
bet it'll be someone else though we
don't think doflamingo will be in imple
down forever so the real question is did
a past use of this fruit use this
surgery on unseemingly Ancient Immortal
character like IMU odegorose will law
use it on Luffy to circumvent all the
side effects of the aforementioned
pirate king nidis or will someone more
nefarious use it my I mean Blackbeard's
confrontation with law has us a little
bit worried right now usopp's conquerors
haki usop is the ultimate Underdog in
one piece in a world of super powered
beings he's someone that us normal
weakling humans can really relate to
however in addition to his insane
stamina and pain tolerance he's also
been shown to have some incredible Feats
most notably he unlocked observation
hockey when he stopped sugar from
transforming law and Luffy into toys
Andres Rosa now usop's ultimate goal is
to become a brave Warrior of the sea and
he's teased leading Army's 8 000
soldiers strong while he does seem to be
a fearful coward he's courageous in that
he always overcomes this fear to take on
opponents many times stronger than
himself now this really sounds like a
conqueror to me so maybe usop will join
Luffy and Zorro as a member of the straw
hats that can actually use the rarest
form of haki the straw hat is the one
piece and we're back to the question
what is the one piece it's not the
friends we made along the way that would
just be silly and we already talked
about that now obviously it's the great
treasure that Luffy has had all along as
far back as orange town after buggy
stepped through the straw hats we
learned that it was Luffy's most prized
possession his treasure how then could
even finding Roger's treasure the one
piece surpass the treasure Luffy's
already always has but this Theory Works
more than just on a metaphorical level
what if the straw hat is genuinely
important we know that the half pass
from Roger to shang's to Luffy we also
know that imsama has a massive giant
straw hat in a cold storage on Mourinho
somehow a straw hat is obviously
connected to the ancient history and the
void Century so is it going too far to
think that the hat is the one piece
itself scottburgh band visits crocus
once upon a time in a fateful cover
story that would spawn Theory after
Theory we were treated to everyone's
favorite whale doctor crocus chatting it
up with a mysterious figure that figure
was dressed in an amigasa straw hats and
wano style ropes giving the impression
that this character would be connected
to wano however the wano arc came and
went with no reveal like it to speak of
now since crocus was the doctor for the
Roger Pirates one leading idea for the
identity of this character is none other
than skoppa gabam after other former
Roger Pirates like Rayleigh have become
more and more important players in the
story it seems like it would only make
sense to introduce copper Gabon into the
story as well as Rogers number three
he's been featured prominently in many
of Roger's flashbacks but we still
haven't met him in the current timeline
and really at this rate will we ever
meet Rogers third in commands Admiral
Kobe now it's unlikely that akinu will
promote Kobe to become one of the
highest military powers and besides pink
isn't on the color wheel so how would
Kobe possibly fit in with the current
naming conventions of the Admirals he
doesn't even have an Uber powerful logia
devil fruit either however Kobe's dream
is to become a Marine Admiral so by the
end of the series he will one piece of
the series where characters we love
achieve their dreams and so at the end
of the series sees a Reformation of the
Marines to become a true Force for
justice in the world sword will most
likely lead that transformation and with
them Kobe may become one of the leaders
of the Marines zunisha is pluton on
Fishman Island we learned that the
ancient weapon Poseidon was not a
physical object but a living person
unlike pluton which we'd heard was a
warship Poseidon was actually the
mermaid princess shirahoshi and her
power to control the sea Kings now in
wano we learned that pluton is actually
housed beneath wano however we haven't
quite laid our eyes on it yet so perhaps
the real story is more complicated and
more ability to communicate with and
command the giant elephant zunisha is
somehow connected with the ancient
weapon pluton the devil fruits are
man-made technology Dr vegapunk and sees
a clown's smile technology has allowed
the criminal underworld to produce
artificial devil fruits now most of them
are really pale reflection of real devil
fruit capabilities and many of them are
outright defective however what if all
devil fruits are actually artificial
what if these seemingly magic fruits are
actually technological creations of the
ancient Kingdom could it be that devil
fruits didn't just occur as a byproduct
of nature but were specifically
cultivated and created to imbue great
Powers upon those who eat those fruits
when vegapunk cracked the code to
recreating kaido's fruit he wasn't
imitating nature but recreated an
ancient technology pretty much confirmed
at this point Weevil is whitebeard's
real son when we first were introduced
to Edward Vivo
who didn't get to accomplish a single
thing in the entire story before the
warlord system was disbanded we had a
lot of thoughts thoughts such as what's
this guy's deal and there's no way that
this clown is whitebeard's son Oda
however likes to write his story in a
way that keeps us constantly surprised
and what would be the most surprising
reveal in relation to Weevil well that
this wasn't a lie after all Mr Newgate
you are the father oh are these theories
not enough for you well we're only just
getting started really we've stuck our
heads slightly under the water surface
and now it's time to start swimming
because we've arrived at tier number
three the raids will end in failure yeah
this is a nice one viewers of a certain
YouTuber Mr morge will be very familiar
of this Theory Once Upon a Time fans
hoped for a five-act structure to the
wano arc however as act 3 stretched
longer and longer and longer it became
evident that this would be the climax of
The Ark now this Theory went based on
the 5x structure of many Kabuki plays
which says that at the end of the third
act there is a great tragedy followed by
a final battle in Act 4 and a resolution
in act 5. and so we kept waiting for our
great tragedy we thought perhaps the
scabbard's defeat by kaido would be the
tragedy we thought that maybe Luffy
being thrown into the sea was the
tragedy we thought that Luffy's literal
death was the tragedy and so the idea
popularized and mimified by Mr
mortgage's Channel and his audience was
that after a loss during the raid the
Allies would have to recoup their losses
and then train to fight another day
before ultimately beating kaido however
in the end Oda once again did defy our
expectations here the mythical Cerberus
Zone fruits Blackbeard always works in
threes yes three skulls on his flag he
has three pistols he left three scars on
shanks's face now this popular Theory
says that in addition to his darkness
logia and earthquake paramecia fruit
Blackbeard has a third fruit one that
allows him to have three different devil
fruits in the first place he is a
mythical dog zone model Cerberus this
three-headed dog of Legend just works
too well for the three motive that
Blackbeard has going for him and would
make him a really good boy law is part
of Swords now this is another theory
that's part of a specific YouTuber's
agenda this idea was popularized by
Randy Troy according to him law may be
playing a long game being a secret
Marine agent all along it would mean
that he takes after his mentor rosinance
like so many other one piece characters
who also take after their mentors this
season identity would also make sense
given the interactions between x-strike
another swordmember and LA on wano their
cryptic conversations seem to reveal a
sort of connection between the two
another piece of evidence for the theory
deals with the mysterious Rocky Port
incidents which gave law the reputation
to become a chibukai and in which Kobe
another sword member played the hero
role the straw had devil fruit for those
of you who were not weekly readers or
Watchers during dressrosa this may
surprise you but when the mira mira Nami
was up for grabs there was no shortage
of theories for who would finally eat
that fruit some theories were Sanji who
had already been seen using Flames or
even Frankie for some reason Sabo hadn't
yet re-entered the story and there was
no telling when or if this other brother
would ever return there were even many
theories that an antagonist would eat
the fruit leading to Luffy having to
fight against his brother's devil fruits
however one of the wildest speculations
to come out of this time was that
Luffy's straw hat would get a devil
fruit Luffy himself of course couldn't
eat the fruit since he'd already eaten
the gomukomonomi however ever since
Alabaster we've known that inanimate
objects were able to consume devil
fruits as well and so this actually led
to a ton of people believing that the
straw hat would gain the power to become
fire allowing Luffy and Ace to continue
fighting alongside each other in a way
but hey who knows maybe it's not too
late for the straw hat to get another
fruit vegapunk the Revolutionary why
would Bartholomew Kuma a revolutionary
willingly let vegapunk turn him into a
Mindless machine that does the bidding
of the world governments well according
to this Theory it's because vegapunk has
always been playing both sides of the
conflicts while vegapunk's happy to
accept the government's research and
develop funding they may not agree
politically with the government's goals
they might in fact want to use their
technology to make the world a better
place and only make weapons in a
trade-off that allows them to fund the
research that he really wants to do so
it's possible that Kuma still retains
some of his old will and this has just
been sort of kind of confirmed as we
know it's possible that Kuma still
retains some of his old will as well
after all before going full passifista
he was able to send the straw hats to
their time skip destination as well as
guarding the Thousand Sunny so yeah this
current Arc right now on eckhead island
will reveal a lot more about this the D
is for the dawn Monkey D Luffy
Portugal's DA's Jaguar diesel those with
the D initials are the natural enemy of
the Gods the celestial dragons fear
these members of the d-clan but what
exactly does the E stand for Destiny
destruction death despair delirium
desire dream oh no it's probably not one
of the seven endless it's the wrong
series for that instead we should look
to the original one piece one shot and
the title of the first chapter of the
series Romans Dawn Luffy the New Joy boy
is foretold to bring a new dawn of the
world so what likelier candidate than
this for Luffy's real middle name con di
oriano a lesser known member of the D
Clan and one of the strongest in the
universe is of course condoriano much
like how Trafalgar D water law hit his
true name under the disguise of
Trafalgar law candy oriano hit his D
initial by going by the name condoriano
for those of you unaware Condi oriano is
a member of the straw hat crew that made
his first appearance in the G8 Arc the
only anime Thriller Arc that might as
well be Canon according to the fandom
This truly Mighty member of the d-clan
single-handedly save the straw hats and
enabled them to escape the G8 Base by
bravely allowing himself to be
imprisoned while Robin went on an
Espionage Mission will Oda ever make
condoriano manga Cannon well we can only
hope so Shanks is a Celestial Dragon
this red-haired yonko is hiding
something big what kind of pirate is
allowed to just Waltz into the gorosei's
chambers to hold a private meeting well
the kind that is secretly a Celestial
Dragon this really long-term Theory
stated that Shanks is more than just a
friendly party-loving mentor to Luffy
instead he has a more mysterious and
Sinister past as a member of the tendio
beetle that's pretty much confirmed that
Shanks was still an infant when Roger
took him onto his ship and found him
probably sometime around the god Valley
incident so it's very likely that he was
adopted by Raja and was a survivor of
that Island's disappearance and since
good value was the island of the
celestial dragons there you got it big
mom and the Beast pirates in the grand
Fleet the grand Fleet isn't over yet
having the members of her Lumber's crew
and the tontara is one thing but to
finally and really Take On The World
Government comments the straw hats might
need some truly heavier hitters enter
the cruise of the former yonko big mom
and kaido on hulkig island Luffy made an
ally through the Hartford battle he did
with karakuri the two despite being on
opposite sides came to recognize and
respect each other deeply as individuals
in addition to Big mom's son becoming an
ally kaido's son two befriended Luffy
Yamato wanted to sail away with the crew
but remained to act as juano's protector
from outside forces and so with these
two yonko children as allies it's likely
that with big mom and kaido out of the
picture the remnants of these two crews
could end up fighting on the straw hat
side for the final war the second time
skip especially before the Revelation
that was gear 5 it was a mystery how the
straw hats could ever contend with the
seemingly Invincible yonko oh how did
they deal with insurmountable foes the
last time through a Time skip of course
so why not she put straw hats a second
time but the real reason why this didn't
happen I think that Oda just couldn't
figure out how to make Frankie's
shoulders any bigger honestly The
Immortal gurose a lot of characters in
one piece have flashbacks where we can
see depictions of their younger selves
we're treated to younger in their Prime
versions of old characters like Garb
sengoku or Whitebeard and when
appropriate we see those characters DH
to Children we've seen buggy and Shanks
as kids among many others however during
Robin's flashback we got to see the
gorosei of approximately 20 years ago
and they look exactly the same with Oda
paying such good attention to the
timeline and drawing the details of
characters aging so so well this seems
too big to be just an oversight the
designs of the five Elder stars were
already old but they have not changed
even a tiny bit over this entire time
span which raises the question do they
age at all or are the gurosei immortal
and unaging perhaps they're the same
same rulers of the world government that
were already around during the void
Century Brooke is kuzan's Grandfather
they both have afros they both have ice
powers we say more now as we sink deeper
and deeper the iceberg only grows in
size who could have predicted that what
already seemed so massive above the
surface which contains such unseen
multitudes do the depth of this fandom
really ever end well our craft has now
reached tier level four Croco Mom after
anus Lobby Luffy learned that he had a
dad this dad was none other than Monkey
D Dragon the most wanted man in the
world another thorn in the government
side like father like son however
according to popular scientific sources
in order to be born a Shonen protagonist
also needs a mother on top of a father
however we have no clue whose Luffy mom
is or to We Now Oda has gone on record
saying that he has drawn Luffy's mom in
the series more than one time so who
could it be is it a background
revolutionary still hanging out with
dragon or is it someone we know much
better a certain sir crocodile now as
we've learned at the top of this Iceberg
quite a while ago crocodile might very
well have been female at Birth before
crossing paths with ivankov a
revolutionary who would have been in
proximity to Dragon so before his
transition could he have had a child
with dragon a certain Luffy perhaps usop
is the narrator The Narrative of one
piece is a very curious figure and how a
greatest literary Scholars have tried to
figure out the exact identity of Saturn
Raider at times this person speaks of
future events as if they're recalling
the story from a later date and thus can
foreshadow what's Yet to Come a prime
example of this is during the formation
of the straw hat Grand Fleet when the
narrator speaks of a cataclysmic event
that they'll one day participate in so
is this narrator just a disembodied on
omniscient omnipresent Voice or is it an
actual character in the story now this
Theory goes that the story of one piece
is actually being told retroactively by
Usopp hopefully this story is just a
little bit more truthful than the ones
that he usually tells Charlotte's Bonnie
Bonnie is Kuma's daughter she is a
princess of the sorbet Kingdom we do
know this now but we didn't always but
what we did know is that Bonnie has pink
hair and who else has pink hair
Charlotte's linlin big mom herself after
all Lola has pink hair and ended up
being big mom's daughter come to think
of it we don't know who Bonnie's mother
is has Kuma been one of big mom's many
ex-husbands all along the Thousand Sunny
is pluton now I know I said at the
beginning of this video that we weren't
talking about that Iceberg but for this
one we're gonna talk about this Iceberg
during water 7 cp9 was searching for the
blueprints to the ancient weapon pluton
pal powerful warship capable of mass
destruction now they thought that
Iceberg had those plans but in actuality
it was his adopted brother Frankie who
had them in the first place and in order
to protect them from falling into the
wrong hands Frankie burned the
blueprints so that the government
couldn't obtain them later on and then
Frankie constructed the straw Hat's new
ship the Thousand Sunny and given
Frankie's intellect and his immense
cyborg inventor brain it's not really
that far-fetched to think that he could
have memorized all of pluton's
blueprints so could some of pluton's
super powerful features have actually
made it into the design of his dream
ship the Thousand Sunny dragon is not
garb's son both of these one-piece
powerhouses hold the monkey family name
but one theory states that they're not
actually blood related while GARP is
Luffy's Grandpa and dragon is Luffy's
father it's not as clear cut out that
dragon is actually garb's son instead
Dragon could have married into the
monkey family and much in the way that
Ace took his mother's last name Dragon
could have taken his wife's last name to
hide some part of his Heritage after all
doesn't Dragon silhouette look
suspiciously like that of roxyzebec
pirate king buggy buggy the clown has
been failing his way upwards throughout
the entire series he started as a lowly
pirate in the East blue but after his
arrest Luffy's Prison Break enabled him
to become one of the first Pirates to
escape from impel down thanks to taking
the credit for the mass Escape as well
as his status as a former Roger crew
member while he was able to elevate
himself to the lofty position of
shichibukai and then things took a turn
for the worst for buggy when his giant
crew members left to join the straw hat
Grand Fleet and then the shichibukai
system was outright dissolved however
thanks to the Cross Guild he is now
cemented his status as one of the four
Empress of the sea if the trend
continues we could see buggy become a
Bonafide King of the the Pirates at
least temporarily after all doesn't it
just feel right for this character to be
present at love tale he's been going in
the direction alongside Luffy and has
such a history with Chang's that him
being with us at the end just seems to
make sense provided that he doesn't get
an inconveniently typed illness again of
course Marco will become an egg Marco
the Phoenix can turn into a phoenix WoW
his epithet is really on the nose
anyways despite his cool healing powers
and powers to fight well we still
haven't really seen this pineapple
activate the most famous of all Phoenix
Powers he still hasn't died and been
reborn so in the final war will Marco be
tragically killed only to avoid death
and resurrect himself in the form of a
brand new far younger Marco I'm really
not that satisfied with Baron tamago
being the only character with an
egg-based transformation and we will not
be satisfied until Marco 2 dies and
becomes an an egg and subsequentially a
tiny Marco baby the will of P listen I I
don't make the rules here if you're a
one-piece character and your name starts
with the letter P you don't get to die
sorry now granted most one piece
characters don't get to die unless
they're in a flashback but this one goes
double for our P named characters Pell
sacrificing himself to save Alabaster
from a massive bomb no problem Pell eats
bomb for breakfast old man pagaya
Connie's dad taking the full brunt of an
old's lightning powers well maybe Luffy
is not the only rubber man after all
peckham's was riddled with bullet holes
and dropped into shark infested waters
don't worry he's all right after all and
the newest member of this club pounds he
inexplicably survived the attacks of all
the big man Pirates the will of p is
really the only force in one piece that
can rival the might of the will of the
and this is why we likely also get to
see our good friend Pedro once again in
the near future Blackbeard will kill
Shanks now we all know that Oda loves to
make us cry Oda also loves giving Luffy
one billion reasons to punch Blackbeard
Blackbeard was largely responsible for
Ace's death he's the main rival for
Luffy's ultimate goal the one piece
Blackbeard has captured Luffy's good
friend Kobe and may do the same for his
chief Ally Law and moreover they have
different taste in pies a conflict that
cannot be overcome by any other means
than violence now we also know that
Shanks and Blackbeard have a history as
well they met each other all the way
back during childhoods Blackbeard even
gave Shanks his signature scars at some
point it was ages and ages ago when we
saw the series first meeting between
yonko when Changs went to Whitebeard to
warn him about teachers machinations I'm
scared to even speak the word so let's
knock on wood as we say blackbeards
might kill Shanks he could even do so
before Luffy is able to reunite with his
mentor and return the straw hats it
would likely be the most emotional
moment in the entire series up to date
but it would definitely make for the
most satisfying Smackdown in manga
history once Luffy got his revenge
Luffy's execution now a lot of classic
Tales are circular they do end where
they began and the story can have a
beautiful poetry to it when the author
uses this type of writing style one
piece opens up with the execution of the
pirate king Goldie Roger it could very
well end with the execution of the next
pirate king Monkey D Luffy if Roger's
death urged a new generation of pirates
to set out to sea Luffy's could too
Luffy is the type of person who wants to
see everyone in the world taste the
freedom and adventure of a life at Sea
and as Bittersweet as Luffy's death
would obviously be it could also make
for a beautiful ending to the series
Baroque works this is another theory by
the YouTuber Randy Troy karibu the
swampiest character in one piece has
stumbled face first into some huge
information about the ancient weapons
information that he's hinted he wants to
bring to a certain someone now prior to
the wano arc it was thought that he
trade his information to either big mom
or kaido but with both of them out of
the picture we're really running out of
options here teach is a prime candidate
but this Theory posts another major
player in the new world it's a crocodile
of the Cross guilds now this theory is
based on the fact that karibu doesn't
look too far off from the concept Arc of
a certain Mr 10. Mr 10 was a baroque
Works member that was mentioned by Vivi
but who we never actually met in the
series however in oda's early sketches
for the character there are some
similarities to karibu the face shape
and generally Wild Hair are pretty true
to kalibu's character design right now
so is it possible that karibu has been a
former underling of crocodile all along
after all crocodile's initial goal in
Alabaster was to obtain obtained the
ancient weapon pluton and now karibu
could help him finally succeed in his
Grand Mission the Emerald City when
straw hats first encountered Bellamy on
Jaya he laughed at them for believing
into myths such as the city of gold and
the one piece now in this list of
ludicrous dreams though he also
mentioned the mysterious Emerald City so
after this the straw hats would
encounter the city of Golden Sky Pia and
Whitebeard has taught us that the one
piece is real so does Bellamy's third
entry the Emerald City also exists I
mean who's to say that Oda doesn't have
time left in the final Saga to shoehorn
in a quick visit of us inspired Arc as
well the lurking Legend gin at Jump
faster 2018 Oda hinted that a lurking
Legend would appear in one piece during
the wano arc he also teased that this
figure would be the straw Hat's
strongest opponent yet now for years
fans have theorized on who this lurking
Legend could possibly be but then again
juano came and went and were still not
had 100 clear who the lurking Legend was
supposed to be the most likely
candidates are imsama or Roxy's back
however the fan Community has come up
with some other truly wild guesses among
these are Shiki the Golden Lion and
other super powerful figures as well the
wildest guess though Jin the former crew
member of Don Creek who the straw hats
encountered during the baratier arc
after all Jin promised to meet our crew
again one day in the new world and we've
been waiting ever since oh look at that
we're halfway there well at this point
we really dare not leave our craft at
least not if we don't want to get the
bends at this depth of fandom the
pressure of the deaths really could
crush us just as the depths of the one
piece lore crush the minds of casual
fans so onwards to tier number five
koshiro is dengiro before we learned
that koshiro was actually dengiro after
going through Grudge induced plastic
surgery many fans noticed that the
dengito and Odin's flashbacks looked a
whole lot like koshiro hold on let's
flip back 1 000 chapters and remind
ourselves who koshiro is especially
since that name is awfully similar to
kyoshiro in the first place now kosiro
is this guy Zorro swordsmanship teacher
and queena's father back from shimotsuka
Village in the East blue and I can't
kind of understand why people would have
thought that this was a candidate for
Dangerous identity I mean just look at
him he clearly just looks like an older
denjudo and we know based on the
shimotsky name that koshiro probably has
some connection to wano but leave it to
Oda to surprise us with a man so angry
his face changed forever Zorro's
Sharingan oh yeah Zorro's eye has been
closed ever since the time skip for some
reason he hasn't been allowed to wear a
classic pirate eye patch because Oda is
saving that eye patch for a very special
character Ed some point now a lot of the
fan base though presumably people who
have watched a lot of Naruto think that
this I can't just be injured no no no
Zorro's closed eye must be hiding an
amazing power up maybe he has a weird
ringed eye like mihawk now or maybe
Zorro just got so lost that he found
himself in the wrong series and ended up
with a sharing gun or a ringing gun or a
byaku gun then Naruto has a lot of
different kind of eyes now that I think
about it the one piece is destroying the
red line now I don't know about you but
as a long time member of the fan
Community the legendary inherited will
theory is the first mega theory that I
really can remember reading many other
super size theories have come after huge
sprawling monoliths dedicated to
uncovering the greatest Mysteries of the
series what is the one piece what
purpose do the ancient weapons serve
what is the will of these so so many
theories with mountains of evidence have
come and gone but one of the first
possibly the first comprehensive and
believable theory was the inherited will
Theory posted on the Arlen Park forums
in case you're unfamiliar with this you
should really read that theory in depth
or watch one of the many YouTube videos
covering it but here's a quick version
the one piece is destroying the red line
literally combining the Seas of the
world into one piece it would likely
take the power of the ancient weapons to
destroy the structure it would mean the
end of marijua and thus it would fulfill
Madame Charlie's prediction of this
drawing Fishman Island below it as well
and it would allow for many of the straw
Hat's dream to come true all at once
Nami would be free to sail all around
the world and map it combining the Seas
would also create the all-blue for Sanji
Brooke would be reunited with laboon the
list goes on and on and on really having
this Theory covered in brief here does
it a bit of a disservice so if you'd
like to see it in a more comprehensive
manner kind of like going through all
the evidence that people have
accumulated why not subscribe and let me
know you want see that people in snowy
countries don't sleep back on drum
Island when Luffy's taking a signomi to
Dr kareja he tells Sanji a rumor that he
once heard he asks Sanji if he knew that
people in snowy countries don't sleep
stating that if they do they'll die now
curiously enough in a classic turn of
oda's got here foreshadowing drum Island
was the very first Arc in which we heard
of a certain Blackbeard yes we first saw
Marshall Lee teach anjaya but Dalton of
the drum Kingdom stated that their
kingdom was attacked by the Blackbeard
Pirates which is why wapal flees with
his Legion of doctors in the first place
now Luffy probably heard this rumor of
people in snowy countries from Shanks
who knew Blackbeard as a child very
likely the rumor isn't about people from
Winter Islands but about Blackbeard
himself who speculated to never sleep a
young Shanks and buggy may have taken
this combined with the fact that teach
is from a winter Island to concoct the
rumor that Lou would repeat on drum
Island setting us up for an eventual
payoff when it came to Blackbeard the D
is a half moon all right we already
talked about this what could the d stand
for Goldie Roger Monkey D Luffy all of
these natural enemy of gods have an
initial in common but one Theory
suggests what if this initial didn't
stand for a name at all maybe it's not
dream or devil or Dawn or anything but
it's a pictogram maybe that D is
actually a half moon now we do know that
moons are important to the series NL is
chilling on one the celestial dragons
and winged races are probably from a
Moon the Moon causes the Mings to
transform into the sulong form so it
wouldn't be that crazy for the d-clan to
also have a connection to the ever
important moons of One Piece perhaps
it's so important to them that it's
literally in their very name Sanji is
dead now we're not just talking about
his fashion sense after stepping through
vegapunk's style changer back during the
zorark there was a ravenous bloodthirsty
part of the fan base who really were
convinced that Sanji was dead let's look
at the facts Nami and the rest of the
crew didn't want to talk about what
happened to Sanji but he was clearly
absent during the arc then we found out
that Sanji was wanted by a yonko and
this was the very first time that we
come face to face with a yonko big Mom
after all in her first introduction was
shown to be a cannibal now this was
still the early Post Time Skip and
people saw signs of a darker and harsher
series from the brutality of doflamingo
to seemingly willingness of Oda to kill
off characters compared to pre-time skip
as evidenced with villains like Virgo
and Monet things were just looking more
violent and so some fans took this to
mean that maybe he turned the story
upside down by having us lose a member
of the crew people also believe that his
only alive wanted poster might have been
a deceptive thing to do so thankfully
this theory was very wrong and our
shitty cook is still kicking the time
travel training montage now this Theory
belongs to the rate will fail Family of
theories it's very odd how little we
actually know about Toki we do know
she's from the void century and
therefore is a Wellspring of important
knowledge and yet after her sacrifice in
Odin's Castle we never hear from her
again however since she flung The
retainers forwards in time it seemed
that perhaps she had jumped forward in
time herself as well I mean when things
were at their most Bleak for the
alliance in the war against kaido and
big mom this Theory stated that Toki
would appear again and would once again
fling our fighters to buy them more time
to prepare against the yonko a second
one I mean Luffy seemed out of his
element especially before he unlocked
Advanced conquerors hockey and gear 5.
so how would he possibly beat kaido
without more time to train and prepare
well by doing the same thing that
kinemon and the others did by going
forward in time some undisclosed amounts
so that he could train further and fight
kaido another day vegapunk the alien Dr
vegapunk has created the wildest
technological marvels of the one piece
World he's created artificial devil
fruits weather Control Systems the
passifista and much much more how could
one scientific genius make so many
amazing inventions we already know that
aliens in the form of space pirates and
possibly the winged races do exist so
perhaps vegapunk is a long lost member
of an advanced Interstellar civilization
introducing his people's Technologies to
the blue sea sadly this one has also
been debunked at this point but the
explanations that we got were maybe even
better than this two-piece what comes
after the one piece the two piece of
course now this in joke in the Phantom
states that after the final chapter
closes on one piece two P's will begin
serialization after all why would Shonen
Jump let their biggest property rest
when they could keep making those sweet
stacks of pirate cash and so just how
Naruto was followed by boruto following
Naruto's son one piece could be followed
by two P's then three p's and so on and
so on until the inevitable heat death of
the universe oh this is a good one
sniper islands where is sniper Island if
soga King is to be believed well it's in
your heart however we all do know that
usop's lies have a tendency to come true
as explored on a previous tier of the
iceberg so what if sniper Island really
is in actual place on the grand line
what if there's an actual sniper King
who USA will either learn from or will
have to go Toe to Toe with now listen I
know we're expecting a giant-sized Argo
one day in elbaf after all we'd love to
get more closure on big mom's story arc
as well as see what our favorite giants
like Dory broggy and hydrogen are up to
but perhaps it's not albaf where USA
will become a brave Warrior of the sea
but sniper Highland itself carrot is the
traitor now in retrospect it seemed
obvious that kandra was the traitor and
Kabuki plays after all the artist
archetype is often cast as a villain or
betrayer his design itself was the
biggest clue as to his true allegiances
however while we did know that there was
a traitor someone who was feeding
information such as the whereabouts of
zo2 the Beast pirates that didn't stop
the fan Community from making all kinds
of guesses one of the wildest that's
carrot new leader of zou and straw hat
in our hearts was the actual Trader all
along she was sneaky enough to
infiltrate the Thousand Sunny after all
and she was mysteriously absent from a
lot of the proceedings on wano
suspicious much Well turns out though
she wasn't a spy she was just sort of
done being plot relevant I guess
I can't remember what light looks like I
can't remember my own name or the faces
of my family at this depth all there is
is one piece with Incredible enthusiasm
onwards to tier number six
pel911 Pell did 911 oh wait that's the
wrong notes Pell is alive because of 9
11. at the end of alabaster pal made the
ultimate sacrifice in Saving everyone
from crocodile's bomb however it just so
happened that this chapter came out
right around the same time as September
11 2001 the terrorist attack on the Twin
Towers in the United States now rumor
has it that Jon and jump editors thought
that it would be bad taste to have a
character killed in a terrorist attack
so close to this event and thus the will
of P was born kaido in the Colosseum in
the d block of the Colosseum Andres Rosa
there was a participant named Meadows he
wore a large leopard skin and a hood and
a cape he had a rather beastly
appearance in fact and since we all knew
of kaido that he was the king of the
beasts one short-lived theory was
actually that this participant was in
fact kaido in Disguise after all at that
point always seen of the yonko was a
retcon silhouette that ended up looking
nothing like kaido's actual appearance
but did share some similarities with
Meadows however once Meadows and the
rest of block D were taken out by
hakubal this Theory didn't have a lack
to really stand on unless there were a
few big metal stands arguing that
Cavendish was Yonka level of course next
Straw Hat smoker who will be the next
Straw Hat it was a huge debate all
throughout wano which Cara joined the
crew with Momo or Tama come along as a
cabin boy or girl would Yamato join well
Oda played us all it was no one I mean
we we technically got jimbei properly
joining the crew during wano but that
was a four gun conclusion since way back
in Fishman Islands though we're still
wondering how did he get away from
hulkig Island in one piece anyways now
some theorists are really looking
forward to trying and predict who will
join up next including me and one guy
that we've already talked about thinks
that smoker will become a straw hat by
the end of the series The Idea goes that
smoker joining the straw hats would
represent the ultimate merging between
the Marines and the straw hats Smoker's
personal journey is after all about
finding Justice and this would mean that
he'd finally realize that it's not the
world government but the straw hats that
are truly on the side of Justice though
I do have to ask will this man's Pride
ever allow him to actually call himself
a pirate Charlotte Nami fun fact we
still don't know who nami's parents are
I mean her real mom will always be
belmare but her birth mother is still
unknown and back in the first half of
the series I would have said it doesn't
even matter who nami's mom is but let's
look at the facts Luffy is the son of
the World's Most Wanted Man and the
grandson of the hero of the Marines
Zorro is definitely somehow related to
the former Diamond of Ringo shimotsuki
usimaru Sanji is a literal Prince of the
German Kingdom usab's father is a member
of a yonko crew are you starting to see
a pattern here so it's really not that
unlikely that Nami will follow in the
footsteps of the other eastblue crew
members and have some sort of really
important lineage but who is she related
to now I'm pretty sure it's not big mom
but this was a really big Theory back
before and in the early days of the
whole cake island arc but if not big mom
then who well maybe we'll find out in a
later Iceberg entry so stay tuned for
that the blonde girl say is sanji's dad
in my heart of Hearts part of me still
wishes that this Theory had turned out
to be true as soon as sanji's wants it
post at the end of Rosa was revealed to
have an only a life status the gears
were turning in the community to figure
out what was so special about Sanji I
mean people had long thought that he was
important due to little hints like his
Mr Prince identity but now he was
looking like all of our suspicions were
truly confirmed and so the primary
suspect one of the gorosei the tall
blonde one with the goatee looks a hell
lot like he could be related to Sanji
and is one of the highest powers in the
world he definitely would have had the
power to influence the wanted posters
after all we didn't know about the VIN
smokes yet and as much as we love our
evil Power Rangers that are the German
Kingdom judge doesn't really look like
he's related to Sanji other than the
blonde hair really but hey if the
gorosei are actually as old as we think
they are maybe there's still hope that
the blonde goto say is sanji's great
great great great grandfather or
something oh these theories are getting
to me shaky was on Roxas crew oh yeah
our favorite Saba ODI bartender and
rayleigh's life partner shaki retired
from piracy decades ago we do know that
however we know that she was a major
player in the world of piracy at some
point as well in the stories detour to
Amazon Lily after wano we learned that
she was actually the former leader of
the Kuja Pirates before Boa Hancock now
in retrospect it makes perfect sense and
it also explains why Rayleigh has such a
close-knit relationship with the
residents of Amazon Lily however before
this reveal the prevailing theory was
that Jackie was actually a member of the
Rocks Pirates after all every other
significant pirate like Whitebeard big
mom kaido and Shiki were all part of his
crew so why not add some more members
also it would give Rayleigh and Shaky's
romance a little bit more of a forbidden
fruit kind of twist a real Romeo and
Juliet Flair but yeah no Amazon Lily it
was and we're more than satisfied with
that really real right right the
celestial dragons are aliens let's just
look at the facts number one Celestial
has two definitions it could mean
Heavenly or mythical or more literally
it could just mean space stuff Sun the
moon the stars and all of these are
celestial bodies and number two these
clowns were space suits and I mean sure
they do justify the giant fishbowls on
their heads by saying that they don't
want to breathe the same air as
commoners however that doesn't change
the fact that the rest of their fashion
looks very outer space and also kind of
weird number three and we've discussed
on previous Iceberg entries already we
already have confirmed aliens in one
piece so what's really a few more here
or there the more the merrier I say
space pirates gripians lunarians and the
space dragons orus was Joy boy now
possibly we may have already met the
original Joy Boy Albert in a roundabout
way Luffy seems to be Joy boy
reincarnated they share a spirit a dream
a soul and even a devil fruit however
they also may have shared a shadow at
one point on Thriller Barrack the straw
hat crew had a tag team fight against
the massive zombie ORS a member of the
ancient Oni race now it would be also
fitting if that zombie that received
Luffy's Shadow from Moria just so
happened to be the previous incarnation
of joyboy we do know after all that the
previous Joy boy was likely a giant of
some kind the Frozen Straw Hat beneath
Marie jaw is the biggest clue for just
that now the biggest issue with this
idea is the timeline the void century
when joyboi was supposed to live was 800
years before the current story but auras
lived about 500 years ago however who
knows how effective morya's carbon
dating is with as much historical
manipulation as the world government
gets up to the discrepancy could
probably be brushed off by Oda akinu is
the leader of Swords Akainu is a
Despicable Marine who has killed
innocent people and his fair share of
Aces okay well one ace but that's still
enough for my count he's ruthless and
will seek out any means necessary to
fulfill his idea of Justice sword is a
secret organization within the Marines
that runs counter to the wishes of the
world government notable members include
Kobe who actively defied Akino during
the Paramount war and would have ended
up thoroughly melted if it weren't for
Shanks stepping in at the last seconds
so in more than just one way a kainu and
sword do seem diametrically opposed to
each other but have you considered this
cover page that shows akinu shirtless
what is that tattoo on his shoulder no
not the tribal one his other shoulder
that's right a sword therefore he must
be the leader of Sword hey I mean a guy
who takes care of bonsai trees must have
a secret soft side as well am I right
shanks's hockey fruits oh oh yeah Shanks
has never been seen to use a devil fruit
in fact there's a very prominent scene
in chapter 1 of Shanks swimming now
could he have theoretically eaten a
devil fruit in the meantime between
Luffy's backstory and the current
storyline oh sure but then shanks's
whole crew seems to be purposefully made
of non-double fruit users also otherwise
it feels like we should probably have
seen at least one power so far what we
have seen Shanks do however are some
crazy displays of hockey arguably he
showed us conquerors hockey in the very
first chapter when he's scared of the
lord of the coast he also easily split
the sky in his confrontation with
Whitebeard but most recently he forced
aramaki out of his logia transformation
and got him to back off the scabbards
from miles away at Sea of the coast of
wano and he did so with nothing but a
long distance bolt of conquerors hockey
in other words this is easily the
wildest and greatest feat of haki we've
seen in the entire series now for a long
time even before this awesome recent
feat this crazy theory has speculated
that shanks's use of haki is a devil
fruit that Shanks is a hockey man who
ate the haki haki no me now granted this
theory was first conceived before we had
any real understanding of what hockey is
it is still extremely unlikely but then
again did you click on an iceberg video
to get sane rational theories now you're
here for the wildest stuff possible good
job and also cool that you're still here
thanks cp0 our big mom's childhood
friends big mom's backstory was one of
the most shocking and gruesome moments
in the entire story sure we've dealt
with slavery Prejudice corrupt
governments and much much more but one
thing we never thought we'd see in one
piece cannibalism so imagine our
surprise when we were treated to Big Mom
eating the worst birthday Feast of all
time in the form of all of her friends
but hear me out what if she didn't eat
all of of them eagle-ed viewers noticed
that a couple of cp0 members who were
present at the region onigashima
somewhat resembled two of the orphans
from mother caramel's orphanage who grew
up alongside Charlotte lindlin and
really this Theory seems to make a lot
of sense firstly the cp0 members Hollow
wearing masks when a character is masked
it seems logical that they're hiding
their identity for some sort of reason
as it would be a big reveal when they
are all a mask so some of us expected to
know some of the cp0 characters after
all some other cp0 members turned out to
be familiar faces like Luchi and Kaku it
also makes sense because mother caramel
was known to sell orphans to the Marines
so if these two survive big mom's
birthday party it would make sense for
them to end up as operatives for the
world government and on top of it all
since big mom was present at the rate
they could play perfectly into
developing her story further after all
we still haven't had the chance to see
her reckon with the truth offer past but
we have seen flags for telling it will
happen such as her daughter pudding
having a memory fruit now having
levduano it does seem like this theory
is kind of dead in the water but it will
still live on somehow in our head Cannon
for now at least done piece it dumpy's
why does that sound familiar oh wait a
minute that's a theory that I'm known
for if you know my channel you might
have seen the best one piece Theory ever
I guess where I dab this Theory from
Japanese YouTuber yuderon now it takes a
solid half hour to explain fully but
here's the gist the original map of Jaya
looks like a giant skull the city of
Golden Sky Pia was located in the
skull's right eye but its left eye is
empty the theory the one piece was
dismissing left eye and currently
resides at the bottom of the strange
hole beneath Anna's Lobby you should
really go watch that one in full ancient
weapon Vivi crocodile's master plan in
Alabaster wasn't simple to take over the
desert country his actual ambition was
to obtain one of the ancient weapons
particularly the battleship pluton which
was rumored to lay beneath the Country
Now by now we do know that pluton is
actually beneath wano but what if
Alabaster was part of the puzzle of the
ancient weapons in fact what if
crocodile had one of the ancient weapons
within His Arms Reach all along now this
theory states that Vivi herself is an
ancient weapon it picked up steam after
the Fishman island arc when all of our
previous Notions of what an ancient
weapon could be were shattered
completely when we found out that the
mermaid princess Shira Hoshi was
Poseidon so just a Shira Hoshi can
command the sea Kings perhaps Vivi is
also the conduit by which some force of
nature either pluton or Uranus is
operated as well in a dark twist with
Vivi now missing could emu be using her
as a key to utilize the destructive
power of Uranus alright we've nearly
reached the bottom down here there
there's just total Darkness Darkness and
one piece theories oh and uh these weird
messed up looking kind of food but
mostly just darkness and one piece
theories theories like the one piece is
on the moon now a large portion of the
fan base hopes that the straw hats are
going to the Moon I mean sure and I'll
could come back to recover on the East
blue but surely Dr vegapunk has a spare
spacecraft lying around somewhere on
Egghead islands and really there are
plenty of mysteries still revolving
around the Moon some of which we already
alluded to on a previous tier of this
Iceberg which feels like five years ago
what better way to explore the origins
of the lunarians and the other winged
races than to go straight to their
Source after all love tale is
ludicrously hard to reach something has
to be preventing Sailors from just
happening on it by chance right I mean
sure it could be terrible storms or
something or being located on the bottom
of the ocean but how cool would it be if
it were actually in outer space itself
preventing the average Joe from just
reaching the one piece the shichibukai
are the seven deadly sins there are
seven Warlords and ever since Fullmetal
Alchemists named their homunculi after
the seven deadly sins every group of
characters featuring seven members has
been theorized as being a representative
of those sins unfortunately while there
are some good comparisons within the
group the analogy kind of falls apart if
you think about it for a little bit
longer the clearest ones are probably
Hancock as lust and gecko Moria as sloth
Hancock because her powers rely on
people being infatuated with her and
Moria because he gave up Ambitions of
traveling the new world and traded them
for building a zombie army to do the
dirty work for him though Flamingo and
crocodile could probably be pride and or
greed but what members of the
shichibukai aren't prideful and greedy
really I mean they're Pirates it does
kind of come with the territory wrath
and envy are where things really fall
apart from me I mean jinbei could maybe
be wrathful because he's angry sometimes
but really he's usually a pretty chill
dude when what is Kuma envious off
having free will like who knows well
it's fun to speculate about the seven
deadly warlords just they just yeah
don't hold up to scrutiny I think Nami
will control Uranus Nami is one piece's
number one meteorologist thanks to tools
like the climate act technology of
witheria and now big mom's homie Zeus
Nami has formidable weather-based Powers
but how could they become even more
powerful what will nami's final upgrade
be well according to this Theory it'll
be the ancient weapon Uranus itself now
the real only evidence if you can call
it that is that Uranus is a god of the
sky and weather and I mean weather also
comes from the sky unfortunately for
Nami recent events would suggest that
it's actually even when the government
who do control this powerful weapon at
least if that is what that giant Sky
laser beam is actually in the ends
Christianity exists in one piece getting
religious sorry Anno but in one piece
there are plenty of gods ready to
Dethrone you obviously we have things
like sengoku's Golden Buddha fruit and
Luffy being compared to the wisdom king
or the sun god Nika but but apparently
there are plenty of One Piece characters
who do believe and worship the Christian
Gods huh now the implications of this
have not been explored in the story but
Kuma is clearly carrying around a Bible
the Christian holy book we've also got
the cultists who are trying to worship
Satan but ended up with Brook instead we
have references like the Adam and Eve
tree and all of this begs the question
is there a one-piece Jesus rocks is emu
what if rocks actually wasn't defeated
on God Valley what if he actually did
fulfill his goal and conquered the World
by reaching the empty throne and claimed
it for himself now this theory was
especially popularized by Archer the
library of a Horus fan comic the return
to the reverie which explored an
alternate idea of what could have
occurred after the revelry Arc in it we
see emu uncovering himself as rocks and
doing battle against the Revolutionary
Army if you haven't read it it's really
really well made like the production
quality is insane it's so professionally
done it does look like a real chapter
I'd say fire Festival ghosts this one
was a huge part of Joy boy Theory's
wanna Arc agenda another YouTuber in
Japan the tradition of holding a fire
Festival often connects to the idea of
sending of spirits or reconnecting with
ancestors the thought was that the fire
Festival could literally see ghosts of
past characters manifest during the raid
at various points in the arc characters
impersonated characters long saw debt
conjuro created a fake Odin black Maria
created the illusion of Robin's mother
and Professor Clover and so this Theory
said that these characters and more
would come back to create some very
emotional moments in which flashback
characters could see how much the straw
hats have grown and Odin reappearing
would of course have truly struck fear
into kaido's heart add this to the list
of theories that were a little bit sad
that they didn't come true Snow Bunny
carrots in Punk Hazard we learned that
when a devil fruit user dies the fruit
root reincarnates into a nearby piece of
normal fruit after Caesar's pet Smiley
the Doomsday Axolotl died a random
nearby fruit turned into the Axolotl
Zone however Smiley wasn't the only
fruit user to diet in Punk Hazard Monet
the snow fruit user also died now we're
not sure about Punk hazard's fruit
reserves but we do know that the
Thousand Sunny happens to have a few of
nami's treasured orange trees growing on
it and so the thought behind this theory
was that Monet's no fruit would have
jumped onto one of these oranges to then
be unwittingly eaten by someone on the
straw hat ship a prime suspect for this
after though was none other than carrots
after the sunny sailed away from Punk
Hazard a strange panel featured a bunch
of bunnies depicted in waves beneath the
ship which was thought to be
foreshadowing to the snow bunny carrots
evil Shanks what if Shanks but evil now
even though shanks's presence has loomed
over the series since the very first
chapter we know shockingly little about
his actual motivation we do know he's
wildly powerful able to stop the
Paramount war with a single sentence and
now we know that he's making his move to
claim the one piece we also do know that
he stole the gumugumunomi from the world
government and might have known that it
was much much more than meets the eye
and we know that he can see an audience
with the gorosei at his own whim now all
of these details add up to make a super
mysterious character and as Luffy's hero
we've always thought of him as a great
man but could there be a darker and more
evil side to this emperor of the sea
could he be orchestrating events in the
series for his own dark purposes sea
Stone sandals oh yeah this one oh yeah
so the year is 2008. the arc is Saba ODI
archipelago and the one piece fanbase
would not yet know the wonders of hockey
now at this point in the story lokias
were still pretty much Unstoppable
because of their intangibility and they
were seemingly no ways to overcome them
unless you had a natural counter and so
the only way way so far we've seen Logan
users be defeated by Luffy was when he
used water to defeat crocodile and when
he resisted an old's lightning powers
with his rubbery body however there was
one exception to this sea Stone smoke a
sea Stone had been seen to incapacitate
devil fruit users and sea Stone
handcuffs or jail cells could keep them
captive so when we saw dark King
Rayleigh stop kizarro and Saba ODI a man
made of light with just a kick the fan
base jumped to some conclusions
obviously the key to his stopping the
Admiral was in his Footwear his uh
c-stone sandals Pangea Kingdom the base
of operations for the world government
is Pangea Castle now this idea states
that Pangea Castle is actually named for
the ancient Kingdom itself after the
kingdom fell the world government took
its place and took up residence in
Pangea Castle moreover Pangea Castle
which sits on top of the red line is
named for its supercontinent which once
existed on our real Earth that was
before the tectonic movement separated
the world into the seven continents we
now know today now the theory goes that
such a continent may have existed in the
one piece world as well before the world
was separated into many islands and
Scattered across the sea with the only
continent remaining being the red line
the mihawk homie in the beginning of the
whole cake Island arik we received the
Revelation that big mom wielded the soul
soul fruit now this fruit filled her
Island to the brim with all sorts of
whimsical creatures who were imbued with
parts of her soul the trees food and
anything really was transformed into
things called homies we also learned
that as a tax for living in whole cake
Island a small portion of each Citizen's
Soul was taken each year to empower the
emperor now when we learned about her
soul manipulation abilities the
community was a buzz trying to figure
out implications of this ability and
particularly one homie named the crane
Rider Randolph a gallant rabbit Warrior
made some View is very curious they
noticed some surface level similarities
between Randolph and the warlord Dracula
mihawk and thus speculated that Randolph
may have just held a portion of the
shitibukai Soul Panda man the guardian
angel now there is a special force
watching over the world of One Piece the
panda man now this Easter egg character
has been hidden in tons of chapters all
throughout the series he's practically
omnipresent throughout the story so is
it really a mereco incident that he's
hiding in the panels of so many chapters
seemingly following the straw hats
around on their Adventures perhaps he is
more than just an Easter egg and this
Panda headed hero is actually the straw
Hat's Guardian Angel Django's power up
back in syrup Village one member of the
Kudo Pirates was none other than Django
the hypnotist at one point he even
hypnotized members of his own crew to
increase their strength when they were
fighting against the straw hats however
as a gag Luffy was also hypnotized and
started rampaging as well now this
Theory suggests that Luffy's insane
strength throughout the entire series is
all thanks to this hypnotism received by
Django in fact Luffy is still hypnotized
even now it's not just his will or devil
fruit he refuses to ever give up no
matter how many times he's been defeated
because he's literally compelled to do
so alright a vast mates 20 000 leaks
under the one PC I never thought we'd
make it this steep I've just been told
that the submarine here is out of
rations and I'm afraid we're not long
for this world but at least before I go
we get to explore the most absurd
one-piece theories of all time here down
at tier level 8. kaido is a pornoglyph
you heard me right kaido is a poneoglyph
at least that's what some people used to
think now all that we really knew about
the Fearsome kaido the world's strongest
creature is that he was said to be
indestructible nothing could harm this
Beast
and you know what else is said to be
indestructible Pony glyphs therefore the
only logical conclusion is that kaido
was a pony glyph that ate an ancient Oni
devil fruit the devil fruits are people
now we've already had more cannibalism
in one piece than in any other average
story which you know not a high bar to
cross but still however as we learn the
secrets of the ancient Kingdom it might
be that one piece gets another one of
these super crazy twists that's right
devil fruits are made of people now we
have actually seen some possible
evidence of past users Wills or memories
or personalities even being embedded
into fruits and it's unclear whether
fruits might impact the user's
personality is Luffy emblematic or
freedom because he ate the fruit or did
he eat the fruit because he's emblematic
of Freedom same with though Flamingo
being manipulated and controlling and so
on and so forth so we're devil fruits
possibly created from people who
happened to have these abilities and
were their personalities or Souls passed
alongside with those abilities emu di
Nami now just as we discussed earlier
that Nami could possibly be big mom's
child this theory is also predicated on
the idea that we don't quite know yet
who nami's birth parents are so let's go
crazy with it Nami is the daughter of
emu and let's throw in the D initial as
well for good measure this would really
make for a Darth Vader level twist and
hey if she joins up with her pops maybe
he'll let her control the ancient weapon
Uranus after all it's a win-win other
than the islands that get obliterated on
the map but
Sanji is Uranus okay hear me out back in
the day mines were blown when we found
out that shirahoshi was Poseidon we had
absolutely no idea that an ancient
weapon being a person was even a
possibility the mermaid princess is big
but she's no worship so suddenly
everything was on the table and the
fanbase was wrecking out Collective
brain lines to figure out which
characters could be other ancient
weapons now conveniently around this
same time on Fishman Island Sanji had
just revealed his Skywalk ability and
Uranus is a god of the sky Ergo Sanji is
Uranus simply as that really Karina is
mihawk koenas tashiki broke kuina is
mihawk very woke now obviously quina
didn't fall down the stairs that would
be such an unceremonious death clearly
what actually happened is that Karina
left with the revolutionaries when
Dragon docked at shimotsukere when Zorro
was still a child she was always told
growing up that as a girl she could
never become the world's greatest
swordsman therefore she asked ivankov to
perform a sex change on her afterwards
taking on the new name dracul mihawk he
became the world's strongest swordsman
the one piece is in barto's briefcase in
the Colosseum Andres Rosa when we first
first met bartolomeo he was carrying a
mysterious briefcase chained to his
wrist and there was a panel that focused
heavily on this briefcase suggesting
that it was very important the briefcase
was never mentioned or seen ever again
and so obviously we can logically
conclude that its contents were none
other than the one piece Bartow had
found it in order to make an offering to
Luffy so that he could make his hero the
king of pirates however he was so
Starstruck when he met the straw hat the
first time that he promptly forgot all
about it and left the briefcase in
dressrosa Kobe is the final boss the
first Marine that Luffy ever met on his
journey not counting his childhood
Guardian GARP was Kobe the pink-haired
Cabin Boy of the alvita Pirates now
Luffy had had a dream to become the
pirate king and Kobe had the dream to
become a Marine Admiral and while these
two have been allies and Friends
throughout the series their two goals
are kind of diametrically opposed to
each other and so a truly wild twist to
the series would be instead of Luffy
going up against someone like a kainu
would be to go up against one of his
oldest friends in a clash of ideals Kobe
would need one hell of a power up to
contend with the future pirate king but
if it would make for a memorable ending
I mean I think it would who knows big
mom the NHC 10 addict we all know that
big mom has had some really serious
hunger pains but so do all of the no-so
little kids that the crew rescued from
Punk hazards now that's a pretty strange
coincidence that these seemingly
unrelated characters both suffer from
the same condition however there are a
few connections between the two groups
big mom had contracted Caesar Clown to
do work for her and he was also the one
who was performing gigantification
experiments on the children the
children's hunger pains and subsequent
terrible Rampages were due to withdrawal
from an addictive drug called NHC 10. he
fed this drug to the children by hiding
it inside candy much like all the sweet
treats that big mom loves so so much big
mom is also notably Giant and compare to
normal humans so was she a failed
experiment before being dropped off an
elbaf is she too an NHC 10 addict who is
constantly feeling some major withdrawal
symptoms from the drug Oda is
pro-monarchy now one would think that
with story features like the
Revolutionary Army and the Luffy's
General opposition to Authority and
declaring war on a literal world
government that Oda is very against
authoritarian regimes however that might
not be true at all Oda seemingly loves
kingdoms with one Central Authority a
monarch so long as they have a very nice
king or queen instead of an evil ruler
from Vivi to shirahoshi to Rebecca the
strawheads love their monarchs and it's
just when it's a pirate or waffle in
charge that the system of government
really falls apart in the story Rockstar
is rocks
oh boy Rox diesel back was a Scourge
upon the one piece World striking fear
into the hearts of the world government
and other Pirates alike Rockstar is a
rookie who somehow landed a spot on
shanks's crew now observant viewers will
realize that the name Rockstar has rocks
right in it coincidence I think not it's
not impossible that rocks did not die
but simply waited and bited his time
until his old rival Roger passed away
and since Shanks is very likely a
Celestial Dragon who was found on God
Valley he's likely just waiting for his
chance to take out God Valley's last
survivor Zorro's Bounty Hunter long con
this is might actually be my favorite so
when Luffy recruits rarana Zorro The
Swordsman laughs him off after all he
was literally known as the pirate Hunter
Zorro he was one of the most infamous
bounty hunters in the East blue so this
Theory says that Zorro's membership in
the crew is actually a really long game
he may seem like the most unwaveringly
loyal crewmate and vice captain of all
time however in actuality he protects
Luffy at all costs because Luffy is his
prey after all at the beginning of the
story Luffy's bounty is nothing however
if Luffy can achieve his dream of
becoming the pirate king well he'll have
the highest Bounty ever known and once
sorrow brings him into the Marines well
he'll be set for life void Century
Bonnie uh-oh uh this theory is not
looking too great lately now that we're
in the Egghead island arc we've learned
that in actuality Bonnie is Kuma's
daughter and is learning about the void
Century along with the rest of the straw
hats from vegapunk however just as it
was once speculated that she might be
related to big mom her true age has
always been a pressing question if she
can manipulate her age at will it seems
possible that she could be much much
older than she let on like void Century
old which could have explained what
Blackbeard wanted with her however now
it seems that her preferred age is
simply her actual age which is kind of
sad game on is the one piece I actually
lied earlier when I said that the one
piece was the friends we made along the
way or that it was the straw hat or was
the moon or in bartolomeo's briefcase
because obviously the real one piece is
not the friends we made along the way it
was one specific friend that we made
along the way gaimon I mean if you
really think about it for more than
three seconds it kind of becomes obvious
first off he's on an island of rare
animals what else is rare the one piece
secondly gaimon is what a treasure chest
and what is the one piece huh a treasure
a really Oda couldn't have foreshadowed
this Revelation any harder so Checkmate
theorists I'd say Okay so this was
enough Iceberg to sink the 10 Titanic
captains but Against All Odds we
actually made it through together all
the way like you're still here which is
crazy whether our sanity is still intact
that is Up For Debate but that Iceberg
couldn't stop us because dreams never
die
if you need another one hour video after
this one because you're that type of
crazy well you can watch my mega one
analysis right here